في الوقت الراهن يفرض علينا الوضع الطارئ
ان ندعم قدره الشعب الاوكرانيه على الصمود
من اجل ان تتجاوز اوكرانيا هذا الشتاء
الطويل ما يرفع جهدا الشامل بالاضافه الى
ما سبق تقديمه الى 125 مليون يورو كمساعده
عاجله
عبد الله ملكاوي من الى قصر الى مركز
المؤتمرات في وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
اهلا بك عبد الله همم نبدا بالحضور الدوله
الكبيره كالصين على سبيل المثال هي الغائب
الاكبر هناك سفراء دول الخليج الهند حدثنا
عن من يشارك وما حجم الاموال المعلن حتى
الان
نعم 46 دوله بالاضافه الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده بالتاكيد دول
في غايه الاهميه كان ااا حضورها هنا في
هذا المؤتمر بحسب تصريحات السلطات
الفرنسيه كالهند واندونيسيا من الصين لكن
ايضا دول الخليج على صعيدي سفرائها همم
السعوديه والامارات العربيه المتحده وعمان
والبحرين وقطر همم ايضا كان هناك حضور
للرئيس السويسري ايضا رئيس الوزراء من
لوكسمبرج وبعض الوزراء والشخصيات وايضا
كان هناك حوالي اربعه 24
منظمه دوليه امميه وغير حكوميه ايضا شاركت
في هذا المؤتمر الذي يهدف بالتاكيد الى
تقديم المساعدات وايصالها الى الاوكرانيين
خلال هذه الفتره العصيبه فتره همم الحرب
همم كان اعلن عن 400 مليون ك من ادنى من
المتبرعين في هذا المؤتمر لكن المؤتمر
الصحفي الذي همم
ينعقد الان لرئيسه او لوزيره الخارجيه
ووزيره اوروبا والخارجيه الفرنسيه كاثرين
كولونا قالت ان المبلغ تجاوز المليار يورو
من كافه المتبرعين وهو يعني فاقه همم
الاعمال التي كانت تعقد على هذا المؤتمر
وان هذا المليار هو فقط منحه من خلال هذا
المؤتمر ليس له علاقه لا بقروض ولا بمنح
كانت همم وعدت بها الدول مسبقا لاوكرانيا
على همم حذاء لكن هذا المؤتمر هذا المليار
هو ارقام جديده هي همم مبلغ جديد سيتم
تمويل السلطات الاوكرانيه به ويهدف هذا
المؤتمر ايضا الى تنسيق هذه الجهود لان
المساعدات كانت تذهب من كل طرف ومن كل
دوله ومن كل منظمه بشكل خاص من جهتها لكن
هذا المؤتمر سيكون القناه الجديده همم وهو
بالتوافق مع السلطات الاوكرانيين مع
الرئيس زيننسكي لتحديد الاحتياجات التي
همم
تمر بها اوكرانيا في هذه المرحله وكيفيه
الرد عليها من كافه هذه اي تجميع كافه هذه
المساعدات والتبرعات ومن ثم توزيعها بحسب
الاحتياجات وتحديد هذه الاحتياجات مثلا تم
الحديث عن مولدات كهرباء هم بامس الحاجه
اليها خاصه حاليا في همم فصل الشتاء ايضا
عن باصات وحافلات لنقل الطلاب لانه هناك
نقص في هذا المجال ايضا عن المختبرات لفحص
الحمض النووي الدي ان ايه خاصه في ظل
الكشف عن مجازر جماعيه ومقابر جماعيه
خلفتها القوات الروسيه وبالتالي تم تحديد
العلويات والطرق التي ستمر عمرها هذه
المساعده
هو مليار يورو فقط للتاكيد هو حجم همم
المساعدات التي تم الاعلان عنها حتى الان
هذا هو المبلغ المعلن عنه مليار يورو